en el día 2 del estallido entre israel y
la yihad islámica nuevos ataques
israelíes golpean la franja de gaza- la
yihad islámica disparó cohetes contra
israel
la mayoría de los cuales fueron
interceptados por el sistema cúpula de
hierro desde que comenzó su ofensiva
israelã centrado a sus ataques en los
agentes de la yihad islámica publicando
imágenes de arrestos durante la noche en
cisjordania y entregando detalles sobre
las personas que dicen que fueron
atacadas mientras tanto los palestinos
lloraron a quienes perdieron la vida
desde que comenzó la violencia tanto
civiles como militantes con algunos
llamados a la venganza muchos estaban
enojados o temían una mayor escalada
todo cayó sobre nosotros gracias a dios
nos salvó pero mi esposa se rompió la
mano y mi hijo fue alcanzado por una
metralla en el cuerpo
por supuesto estos dos días afectaron a
la gente moverse es difícil porque la
gente tiene miedo a las guerras
especialmente a esta
el mar verde meses
este último ciclo de violencia comenzó
con el asesinato de un alto comandante
de la yihad islámica que israel dice que
estaba destinado a prevenir un ataque
del grupo
a través de la fuerza debería llevaron a
cabo decenas de ataques con aviones de
combate y vehículos aéreos no tripulados
para frustrar a altos funcionarios de la
yihad islámica y operativos terroristas
en las unidades antitanque y en las
unidades del frente que amenazaban a las
comunidades del sur un factor clave es y
hamás que controla la franja de gaza
decide unirse a la lucha egipto qatar y
la onu han estado tratando de mediar en
una tregua mientras que la guardia
revolucionaria de irán asegura que
israel pagará el precio por lo ocurrido